Good morning. Thank you all for coming.
It's great to see such a full room today.
Uh, I'm delighted to
welcome Dana Staf. Uh,
Dennis staff fell in love with
cephalopods at the age of 10. Uh,
she began to keep them as pets in a home
aquarium and learned to scuba dive in
order to meet more of them in the wild.
She went on to study.
Pygmy is in Santa Barbara,
cuddle fish in Australia,
reef squid in Bermuda and
finally completed her phd
on quote reproduction and
early life of the Humboldt squid or quote,
squid sex and babies at Stanford.
Her first book titled Squid Empire.
The rise and fall of the CEPHALOPODS
has been named one of the best science
books of 2017 by NPR science Friday.
She lives in San Jose in the physical
world and that Cephalonia podiatrists.
Dot. Come on mine. Please join me in
welcoming to Google dentist's staff.
Thank you so much.
It's really wonderful to be here.
No, it was probably hard to take
time away from your work to come.
And I appreciate that everybody was
able to do that to be here and that for
anybody watching it, uh,
remotely or in the future.
Thank you for taking time out of whatever
else you were going to be doing to see
this. Um, I am here to talk
to you about cephalopods,
which is a difficult word
to say all by itself.
And so we can just call them
squid and octopus and relatives.
And in particular,
the story that I want to tell about them
is a story that parallels the history
of dinosaurs.
And the reason that this particular
story about cephalopods has caught my
attention to the point that I wrote a
whole book about it is that I started to
realize that the, the deep evolutionary
history of squid and octopus is,
was even more fascinating then the famous
dinosaurs that we all know and love
from the age of three or four.
And yet nobody knows anything about it.
So I'm going to tell you
today why cephalopods are
even better than dinosaurs.
And in particular trying
to spark something that I
like to call the cephalopod
renaissance.
And this is a reference to something
called the dinosaur renaissance. Um,
that happened in the latter
part of the last century. Uh,
we often don't even realize it today,
but dinosaurs used to be seen as really
slow and really stupid and really
boring. And that was this. Um,
this view up here or this drawing was
done in late 18 hundreds with the view
persisted into the early
19 hundreds as well.
The dinosaurs were too heavy to even
walk around. They had to live in swamps.
They were too stupid to survive,
so they were already doomed by the time
and asteroid hit and ended their rain.
Um,
and so no one was actually that interested
in their lives and behavior until a
scientist named Bob backer in the
60s started to describe dinosaurs in
particular one famous dinosaur named
Diana Nicus. And realize that it was,
it moved quickly. It was very
active. It was very energetic. Um,
and this actually became the whole view
of dinosaurs that we now know as complex
creatures with social lives and behaviors
and all their relationships with birds
and the feathers and the warm bloodedness.
And all of this stuff is called the
dinosaur renaissance and gives us this
beautiful view of the,
the delightfully ferocious
warm blooded cuddly dinosaurs.
Uh,
then we know today,
and of course this dinosaur renaissance
happened in the scientific literature,
championed by scientists, but it
quickly seeped out into popular culture,
giving us all of these,
uh,
this is why we have Jurassic
Park and all of its sequels.
This is why we have so many sticker books
full of dinosaurs and video games full
of dinosaurs.
It's because there was this shift and
scientific thinking about dinosaurs really
realizing how complex and
interesting their lives really were.
And so I'm here to show you the same
thing happening with cephalopods,
except they're even better. Um, and one
of the ways in which they're even better,
um,
is that they have so many representatives
around today that we can learn from.
Of course, we have representatives of
dinosaurs today. We have birds. Um,
and similarly to that,
we can think about what do we have the
squid and octopus that we have today and
what makes them,
what they are.
A lot of the things that we think
of our tentacles, um, camouflage,
there's actually a cuddle
fish here hiding in the sand.
It's a little arms are coming down
there and it has two little black eyes.
The amazing camouflage abilities
of these animals are legendary.
And of course they can also score ink if
that doesn't work and they have to get
away quickly. And it's all
connected to their intelligence,
the very large brains, their ability
to coordinate the camouflage,
the behavior to coordinate all of those
arms and tentacles moving together.
It all has to be done by a very
complex central nervous system.
And these are all the things that we know
and love about cephalopods today about
squid and octopus.
And one of the things that is most
fascinating to me about their evolutionary
history is that none of these things
originally made the first cephalopod.
The very first cephalopod was
made by a shell of buoyant Shell.
And that was what separated the early
cephalopods from all of the other snails
and mollusks and other clams and things
that were living on the sea floor.
And to understand how this
happened, we have to go way, way,
way back in time because cephalopods
are twice as old as dinosaurs.
So we have to go before humans obviously.
But also way back before the dinosaurs
and way that before there was anything on
land. So we're now talking
500 million years ago.
Land is completely
barren except for algae.
I the only psychologists
cologists in the audience.
He didn't even know if psychology is,
it's great.
This is the study of algae and I always
feel bad saying that there's nothing on
land because technically there were some
little cells of algae swooshing around
here and there, but there was
nothing large and interesting.
Everything large and
interesting was in the ocean.
And this is what it looked like. Try
the whites mostly, um, and more algae,
but larger LG this time, all
of these big plants here, um,
and almost everything was on the
sea floor. So even underwater,
there weren't any large
animals swimming around.
This is way before fish and sharks,
no marine reptiles, no marine mammals.
And so anything that was swimming was
just kind of a little shrimpy thing and
most of the large animals were crawling
on or burrowing in or scrabbling around
over the sea floor because that was
the interesting place where all of the
interactions were taking place.
And one little fellow who was doing
this along with everybody else is this
little snail like creature that's thought
to be one of the first cephalopods are
the first ancestors of cephalopods.
And the shell of this little fellow
shows us how they became the wondrous
creatures that they turned into.
And it happened because this is,
this is diagrams,
cross sections of the shell.
So here's our little friend still
smooching around on the sea floor,
but you can see that inside the
shell there are some little chambers.
The chamber is filled with the
yellow color, are sectioned off,
separated from the rest of the animal,
and they're filled with buoyant gas.
And once enough of those chambers formed
the gas and then was able to offset the
weight of the Shell and the weight of
the animal and lift it right up into the
water column.
So that's what you see at the top.
There is the first real true cephalopod
that had a chambered shell with buoyant
gas inside the chambers.
It was able to move around in the water
column and there were some of the first
animals to really be swimmers.
And not only were they swimmers,
but they could get enormous because
once the shell is no longer heavy,
now the shell carries
its own buoyancy with it.
It can get arbitrarily large.
Um,
and so cephalopods literally rose above
the competition. I like to say this, um,
this is a very authentic drying of the
early Ordovician seas except for the
scuba diver who's sort of out of place,
but she's just there to show scale to
show you how incredibly large these
animals got this straight shelled
cephalopods are going off of the screen.
They were large enough that the shells
would have reached the entire length of
this room. And then we don't
even know if they had tentacles,
how many tentacles they had,
how long those tentacles might've been.
So they really were some
of the first sea monsters,
the first sea monsters in the whole ocean,
which meant in the whole world because
there was still nothing large on land.
And so on top here again with a,
at this time with a snappily dressed
men for scale. Um, we have camera,
Sarah's one of those really long s child,
straight shelled early cephalopods. Um,
and then this curl shelled cephalopod
down here as that type of cephalopod cut
an ammonite that lived much later.
Um,
that one actually lived in the oceans at
the same time as dinosaurs were living
on land. It's Thea sores were swimming
around. If they were big enough,
they were probably
trying to eat these guys.
Moses sores were probably eating them.
Um,
and you can see that the shells got
large enough that a person could climb
inside of that Shell.
They were really tremendous throughout
the hundreds of millions of years that
they lived in the ocean.
And for most of this time,
they all had these big shells that carried
their own buoyancy around with them.
And so they were,
they were sort of freed up
to move wherever they wanted
to be as large as they
could possibly evolve to be.
And they were living there doing
all of this at the same time,
both long before and also at the same
time as the dinosaurs were doing all of
their crazy things on land.
And then what really blows my mind is
that they faced extinction at the same
time,
at the end of the Cretaceous
when an asteroid smashed
into the planet and all of
the non avian dinosaurs went extinct.
So did most of the cephalopods
it was a very bad day.
They don't know exactly what happened.
Um,
we do know that the asteroid hit
that it changed the global climate.
It probably acidified the surface
areas of the oceans tremendously. Um,
there were probably lots of
fires all over the place.
It's still a matter of active research.
Why this really bad day cause
such specific extinctions?
Because you remember not
everything went extinct.
It was not a really bad day for everybody.
We still have all of our birds,
all of our avian dinosaurs,
and we still have all of our squid and
octopus and Nautilus and cuddle fish that
we talked about.
Uh,
and so this is a very interesting
question about why some of these animals
survived one of the worst days on the
planet and so many others went extinct.
And it makes it very interesting to study
both of these large famous groups that
faced extinction, the dinosaurs and
the cephalopods. Now I have to wonder.
So cephalopods were huge ancient monsters.
They live before the dinosaurs and
through the time of the dinosaurs and they
had a horrible,
massive murder mystery extinction at the
same time. So why aren't they as cool?
Why don't we know as much?
I mean they are as cool,
but why don't we think there is cool?
Why don't we know as much about them? Um,
and the interesting thing is the sort
of fossils they leave are extremely
different from the sort of fossils
that dinosaur leaves a dinosaur leaves.
Interestingly, cephalopod fossils
are actually way more abundant.
So this is just a picture here of a single
rock that's crammed with these coiled
ammonites. These are ancient
cephalopods, um, that,
that lived around the same
time as the dinosaurs.
If these coiled shells and they're just
the fossilized everywhere. This is,
you know,
single dinosaur thighbone,
which is always a very exciting find
to find even one bone from a dinosaur
skeleton. And you would think that
if they're fossils are more abundant,
we would know more about them.
But the abundance of their fossils
caused an interesting situation for many,
many years,
which is their fossils are so abundant
that geologists just used them as
timestamps.
This is a picture of sort of a,
a cross section through rocks showing
you how rocks get deposited in layers and
then they,
the layers get eroded.
So if you go out digging for
fossils in different places,
you'd might take few different
layers and find different fossils.
And in this case,
these fossils are showing you that even
if you dig in very different places in
the world, you might find the same fossils
from place to place. And that can help,
you know,
the age of the rocks that you're digging
in and those fossils that are reliable
enough to tell you the age
of the rocks are digging in.
And those are called index fossils.
And many,
many index fossils are cephalopods are
ammonites and the relatives of squid
because there so abundant there are so
diverse and there's so easily recognized.
A single shell,
uh,
can be identified to species quite easily
by counting the ribs and figuring out,
um, various, uh,
just taking morphometrics basically
doing little measurements and saying it's
wider than it is tall or
it's fatter than it is tall.
And all of these things
will give you the species.
And so for a long time geologists were
like, these are super useful rocks.
They're the most useful rocks in
the world, but they're not animals.
Nobody was thinking about what were
these things doing when they were alive,
ecologically speaking,
why did they evolve these crazy
shapes and these intricate lines.
And some of them are,
were spiky and some of them were
tiny and some of them were big.
And nobody really thought about those
questions because they were just so useful
as timestamps.
And then this book was published
in 2001 called the ammonites.
That's a really little book.
It was published by a couple of people
at the natural history museum in London.
And they just asked a very simple
question, what might these ammonites,
these ancient cephalopods have
looked like when they were alive?
And more importantly,
what were they doing?
What were they eating
and who is eating them?
And this was kind of a first step towards
creating Diorama's like fourth grade
or was everywhere do with dinosaurs.
And you have the t rex jumping on the
triceratops and taking large bites out of
it. Um, and after this book was published,
people started publishing illustrations
like this and their scientific papers
actually trying to recreate the animals
and think what would they have been
doing? This particular animal
up here is a kind of, um,
uh, kind of ammonite that grows a Greek
curved shell, sort of like a paper clip.
And it's been puzzling scientists
for a really long time thinking,
what did they do? Why would they
bend their shell back again?
It seems like it would be really
awkward for swimming. And then, um,
this is crazy Russian scientist named
Sasha I kept getting was like, well,
maybe they just used it like a paperclip.
If it's shaped like a paper clip,
maybe it works like a paperclip.
And why didn't they just hook themselves
onto some kelp or some underwater
driftwood and live there?
And we have a very sedentary
life, um, and the, you know,
then, and so he drew this
picture and that got published.
And then other scientists published
angry diatribes showing why that couldn't
possibly be the case.
And it was great because science has been
proceeding by leaps and bounds because
people are actually thinking,
talking about it,
building models to see what can happen.
Um,
and so the other thing that is helping
to move this forward is not just the
shift in perspective that
people are finally thinking
about what they would have
looked like, what the cephalopod Diorama's
of the deep sea should look like.
But there are new ways
to look at the fossils.
So technology has proceeded to the point
where we can get more information out
of those old fossils.
And all of these fossils that I
showed you are all well and good.
They're beautiful, it's easy to
count ribs and things like that,
but it doesn't tell you very much
about what the animal was like.
If you look at an articulated
skeleton of a TRX or a Brontosaurus,
you can dream flesh onto it pretty easily.
You see where the neck was,
you see how many legs it had.
You see how long it's tail was.
But all of the soft parts of a cephalopod
are totally missing from this kind of
fossil.
They're just gone and we have no idea
where their mouth was or what number of
tentacles they might've had. But now, um,
paleontologists are making friends with
medical imagery technicians and putting
rocks in two CT scanners,
which I'm told is like
everybody's favorite thing
when they go to the hospital
and find that there are fossils being
run through the CT scanner and everybody
gathers around to see what's going on.
Uh,
because the great thing is if you
look inside these kinds of fossils,
you can actually start to get information
about the soft parts that's missing.
Um, and in this case, this
particular fossil was a
straight shell, the cephalopod.
Um,
and they are,
the CT scanner is not yet finding
how many tentacles it had,
but it is finding the mouth and there's
some pretty stunning images coming out.
This is straight out
of a paper in science,
which is like science papers
are incredibly condensed.
So I'm sorry to show you this image
that's like, ah, too much information.
But basically a on top,
that's a picture of the straight shell
that was put in the CT scanner. Um,
B shows you a sort of cross sectional
view of what sort of the beginning of the
mouth might've looked
like inside that Shao.
And then these shapes here that you're
seeing are the tongue of the animal.
CEPHALOPODS,
squid and octopus and all of their
cousins have these really complex tongues
with a lot of teeth on
them called gradular.
And these tongues of these ancient
cephalopod seem to have been really,
really complex.
They were these sort of folded up origami
shapes with little tongues all over
them that look like they could have
been unfolded and used almost like a
spider's Web to catch plankton to catch
little particles and little animals and
things in the open ocean. So
this tells us all, and this,
this here is,
um,
sort of a three d reconstruction
of how that might have this, uh,
colorful part up there is the regular,
that tongue being unfolded
slowly from kind of a base, uh,
job base where it would have
sat inside the animal. Uh,
and so this is really abstract
for most of us to look at,
but fortunately there are artists who
work with scientists to then make,
because reconstructions like this,
uh,
which doesn't show you the
Radleigh unfortunately,
but it is showing you this beak out of
which the fragile or would have unfolded.
And the whole structure of the Enamel is
based around that knowledge of it being
something that eats plankton.
A lot of other reconstructions,
think of these ancient animals
as being active predators.
Carnivores like squid
and octopus are today.
But this discovery of that complicated
Radleigh that would've just filtered
plankton out of the water has helped a
new interpretation arise thinking like,
okay, they didn't have really long arms
that were muscular for grabbing food.
They just had this
little web of arms maybe,
and then this beat that could open up
and sort of slurp up all of the little
yummy bits and pieces.
And they probably,
this protein at least would not have
been a very good swimmer and would,
would've just sort of gently drifted here.
And they're picking up food,
which is a different thing that
none of the living cephalopods do.
There aren't really any plankton
feeding squid or octopus is,
they tend to be mostly active predators.
And so in a way,
it's sort of like looking at each
dinosaurs and being like, well,
we don't really have any t rexes anymore.
But if you can imagine a chicken
getting that big and being carnivorous,
and what would it be like? Um, so this,
this sort of a nuanced ability to
interpret the fossils is really growing.
I'm creating what seems to me to be
a wonderful time for a cephalopod
renaissance for the extinct cephalopods.
Um, and these are more artists,
reconstructions that are a little bit more
fantastical, but again, like dinosaurs,
we don't really have any
idea what color they were,
so paleo artists can just
kind of go wild with it. Um,
and all of these shapes
are completely realistic.
There are ancient cephalopod fossils
that grew in corkscrews with spikes that
had these weird recurve,
this is sort of a cousin of the paperclip
wine over here that just were super
irregular knots.
Um,
and we still tend to forget why they
had all these super weird shapes.
And while paleontologists are working
on this to figure out what was going on,
it's kind of a perfect time for the
public to become excited about cephalopods
because all of our modern cephalopod squid
and octopus around us today are going
through boom times.
There's what's been referred to as a
global proliferation of cephalopods and
these fingers here are from a paper that
was published in 2016 that was kind of
a review paper gathering
data from fisheries.
And from scientific surveys,
from uh,
octopus's cuddle fish,
squid,
ones that live close to the shore and
ones that live further out and in the deep
and showing that all of them
average together are trending up.
And we are living in a very,
um,
we're very bullish on cephalopods
and the oceans these days.
And the reason seems to be that all of
these animals have evolved away from that
heavy shell. They don't have
a big external shell anymore.
And it's created an extremely flexible
group of animals because they can grow
quickly. They don't have
to build a heavy shell. Um,
they have a lot of babies that can
adapt very quickly to their changing
environment.
And that adaptability and flexibility
seems to be a lot of what's driving this.
Boom.
That and the fact that humans have been
fishing a lot of their main predators
out of the ocean. And so
they're, they're sort of a like,
thanks for removing all of the fish
and now we will go wild situation. Uh,
and of course there are t shirts
that you can buy celebrating this,
a dominance of the cephalopods I
forgot to wore wear mine today,
but you can look them up online.
However,
there are always some exceptions to
this sort of optimistic view of the
cephalopod future.
And I have to mention that there are a
few species that are not doing especially
well that are actually listed
as endangered and they are
deep sea octopus's that
live in the deep cold waters where they
take a very long time to grow and they
reproduce only a few eggs.
And worst of all,
they happen to have neighbors
that are very delicious.
So even though you've probably never
heard of these octopuses that they don't
have common names because nobody
talks about them commonly. Um,
but they live on sea mounts in the deep
sea where orange roughy fish and Scampi
shrimp also live.
And people like to eat those things.
And when people throw down nets into the
deep sea to get the shrimp and the fish,
they also catch these octopuses.
And that's why these particular species
are considered endangered is because
many of them have been accidentally
brought up in these nets and that
populations are suffering.
Um,
and even the squid that
are booming throughout the
oceans and doing really well
have some risks.
Um,
these are a couple of papers that came
out showing that there are problems with
ocean acidification affecting
the early development of squid.
So even though right now they
seem to be doing really well,
the oceans are changing,
they're getting warmer and warmer and
the water is getting more and more acidic
and those things might in the near future
cause that boom trajectory to flatten
out or even get depressed a little
bit depending on how things change,
how much we decided to change things
or not let them go on as normal.
And then of course we still have one
cephalopod with an external shell,
not less. So how are they doing?
Well, I think of Nautilus as,
as sort of a cautionary tale
because there's so beautiful,
they still have that external shell there,
the last cephalopod with an external
shell and they have these beautiful tiger
stripes. And you can
buy them anywhere. Uh,
it turns out they're not
even very expensive. Um,
which is a problem because if you can
buy them anywhere and people will pull
them out of the ocean more and more to
make money and then there won't be any
Novelis's anymore.
And this has become enough of a
problem that in 2017, uh, Sadie's,
the,
which is the international treaty that
regulates all the big endangered species
like Rhinoceros,
Horn and elephant tusks has decided to
start regulating the trade and Novelis
shells as well. Um, which
is very encouraging and, uh,
it's being considered for being listed
on the endangered species act here in the
u s which would also cause
more protections to be put
in place so fewer of them
could be important and um,
and it would hopefully lead to and
longer survival time for this lineage of
shelled cephalopods. The last
ones with that buoyant shell. Um,
and this listing or this,
this possibility of listing cephalopods
here is open for public comment. And, um,
and I went and read all of the public
comments that people had posted in.
One of them in particular
struck me that thought I would,
I would bring it to you.
This is a neuro ethologists named hiking
new mice to it's a neuropathologist
means she studies brain and behavior
and how those things are connected.
And she commented that Nautilus
represents a window to the past,
a unique opportunity to understand
the evolution of the brain,
including its vulnerability.
It's protection is not
only important for us,
but indeed is a moral
imperative for mankind.
So she was of the opinion that she was
presenting this idea that because we have
nautilus is still around today and because
their history goes back 500 million
years before the dinosaurs,
they are really the a one of a kind
opportunity to understand how this
incredible brain that we see an octopus
and squid how would evolve in contrast
to other members of the species.
Um,
and so I think this is a really
beautiful way to connect the study of the
ancient cephalopods and my mission to
get everybody to find them to be just as
cool as dinosaurs with what's going on
currently with the living cephalopods
that we have here today.
It's a really deep lineage here.
This is the history going all the way
back to the Cambrian 500 million years
ago.
Here's our old buddy with the very first
little chambers in its shell all the
way through the really
long straight shelled ones.
This is not exactly to scale because I
didn't have just sort of infinite room to
go off here. Uh, and the, and
then the early coiled cephalopods,
all these super weird shapes of amyloids
that proliferated and then went extinct
at the end of the Cretaceous.
And you'll see over here that the Nautilus
has been just chugging along from its
ancestors all the way back here
towards really the root of the tree.
And it's still a lot of open questions,
a lot of mystery.
Why do they have they changed in a way
that we can't tell from the fossils?
Are they really these unchanged
living fossils. There's a lot of, uh,
of interesting work to be done there.
And meanwhile,
all of the other cephalopods
the octopus is this squid.
The cuddle fish are doing
all of their own things.
A beautiful proliferation that
we're seeing in the oceans today.
And by comparing all of this stuff,
all of the deep time history with
all of the modern diversity, um,
we're really in a,
in a beautiful place to understand
this group like never before.
And it's a group that is uniquely suited
to sort of shedding light on all of
life on earth because it's really the
farthest group from us primates that has
developed intelligence and curiosity
and problem solving skills.
And by comparing the way we do those
things with the way cephalopods do those
things, we can really get
a holistic understanding.
So I just wanted to thank you all finally
for coming and take some questions.
Okay.
All right. Thanks a lot for the
great talk. Uh, I had a question.
How hard would it be to
breeding farm nautilus? Ah,
the Brie, the question is how hard
would it be to breed nautilus? Yes.
Because the,
you were saying that the shelves are so
beautiful and we'll start importing them
and we wanted to put them on dangerous
list as I'm thinking as an alternative,
we could maybe start farming
them, flip the shelves. Yeah,
sure. Is often seen as a, as a solution
if we want more of something, but the,
the wild harvest isn't available.
Can we make them ourselves?
Nautilus are really interesting group
in that regard and interesting species
because they've only just
successfully been bread at all.
Like although people have been keeping
the animals in aquariums for a long time,
they haven't been successfully breeding
and laying eggs and just in the last
year or two at the Monterey Bay aquarium
and they'd been keeping them and
they've actually laid the eggs and
the eggs have actually hatched,
which are two separate challenges
that both had to be overcome.
But there's still a huge gap in having
hatchlings and having those grew up to be
breeding adults. So I
think it's possible. Um, I,
I hope that it happens
because for many reasons.
One is that I think it would just
be very interesting, but it's, uh,
it seems like they're very finicky species
and they're just very specific about
the water requirements
and the food requirements.
And so I believe right now the acquire
the apiarists at the Monterey Bay
aquarium are trying to figure
out what to feed the babies,
to get them to grow up healthy.
And it's,
it takes a long time because
even with good conditions,
it takes them up to 20 years to
reach maturity. So that's, you know,
that's getting to be several aquarists
lifetimes of practice. Um, but, uh,
but I think, I think we'll get
there. I think it'll be very cool.
You said these creatures are
phoned in deep sea, right?
Many of them, yeah. Not all, but
meaning how deep and how
have they adapted to,
because there's a lot of water
pressure, right? Like pretty deep.
Yeah. It's a great question.
Are you more interested in the,
the living ones are the extinct
ones are bald. Okay. Yeah,
so it's a great question. The, um,
the forms that have buoyant shells are
of course always somewhat limited because
they have gas in their shell. And so if
they go too deep, that can implode. Uh,
so even modern nautilus
is and modern cuddle fish,
which have an internal shell that still
has gas chambers in our limited by depth.
So cuddle fish because they're,
their internal shell has quite weak walls.
They can't go much deeper than
one or maybe 200 feet. Uh,
they're quite shallow
because of that. Well, yeah,
shallow for an open ocean and all that.
For us,
a nautilus can do a little bit deeper.
They can get to about 800 feet
for the most ones. And that's,
that's because the show is
much, much thicker. Uh, and the,
the limits of the extinct ones
are of course hard to calculate.
And it's always a little bit tricky to
know where they lived because the shells
sometimes move around before being
a fossilized. And so if there,
if the fossilized shells are found in
sediment that shows that it was in the
deep sea,
well doesn't mean that the animal lived
in the deep sea or does it mean the
animal lived above the
deep sea? Um, but they,
they're thought many of them especially,
let me see if I can go back here. Um,
it was,
this is an interesting,
where am I am annoyed is there,
uh,
these guys in particular, many
of these ammonites had, sorry,
I probably wasn't supposed
to touch that. Um, uh,
had these really complicated
walls between the chambers.
So all of the squiggles
that you here are like,
if each chamber chambers wall between
the Digita was made of sort of tissue
paper and you just scrambled it up and
it's still sealed between the chambers
and held the gas from place to place.
But it had this incredibly complex,
uh, line and it's thought that that
might have sort of somehow spread out the
pressure and allowed them to go
even deeper. Um, and so there,
there's some paleontologist actually
working right now and kind of
reconstructing these as
models and figuring out what
pressure they might've been
been able to survive that.
Yeah.
Um, I don't think, let's see.
I don't think any of them have been
estimated to live deeper than about a
thousand feet.
So I don't think any of the shelled
cephalopods could have lived in what we
think of as the real abyssal deep sea.
Um,
what this the first cephalopods
to colonize that area.
It would have been the ones that
lost the shell. And in fact,
it's thought that the ancestors of squid
who had evolved away from having a,
an external shell and even even their
internal shell doesn't have gas chambers
anymore.
It's just like this sort of thin,
stiff rod that gives them
a little bit of structure.
So there they are basically
insensitive to pressure because they're
incompressible, they're just, there's
no gas spaces, there's no gas bladder,
there's nothing.
And so it's thought that one of the
reasons they might have survived the end
cretaceous impact is that they had a
refuge in the deep sea where things didn't
change so much.
And there,
there are still many squid living
in the very deep seat today.
Speaking of Squid, um, I'm an octopus
person but also loved the Humboldt Squid.
Uh,
I was wondering what drew you to that for
your phd and can you talk a little bit
about that? I would be happy to.
It's a lovely question. So, uh,
the Humboldt squid was the subject of
my phd and it was somewhat accidental
because I went into looking for graduate
programs and Phd advisors just being
kind of a huge cephalopod in that. And I
was like, oh, we're kind of anything like,
are you doing bobtail squid? Are you
doing pygmy octopuses, whatever it is. Um,
and in Monterrey there's a marine
station that is affiliated with Stanford
University.
Some of you may already know this,
it's right next to the Monterey Bay
aquarium and it's called Hopkins Marine
station. And there's a squid lab there.
And the, the scientist who runs that lab,
Bill Gilly was starting up
a whole research program
on Humboldt squid at about
the same time that I was applying
to graduate school. And so I'm,
so I met with him and we,
he talked to me a bit about the squid
and it's like I have never heard of these
guys before but they sound
really cool. And it was also, um,
they were just starting
to expand their range.
So it was a really interesting time to
be working on them that it was a large,
it's a large species.
They still is very large species.
The adults can get about as big as me.
And it's also the biggest squid
fishery in the whole world.
So of all of the different
species of squid that people
eat, little Calamari, um,
these big stakes that are
on Humboldt squid are there.
It's fished by the million tons a year
and most of that is in South America,
Central America and Mexico.
But in the early two thousands,
we were starting to find them on the
California coast and even up into Alaska.
They are getting really far north.
And so it was a really fun time to be a
scientist studying them because we would
get calls from people just
like it's fishermen. We,
we caught a huge squeeze it a giant squid,
what is it? Why are and can you eat it?
Can I sell it? What can I do with it?
Um, and so, um, so it was, it was just,
it was a really neat time and we were
trying to figure out why they were there,
what they were doing.
I ended up working a lot with the babies
and reproduction and my main question
there was thinking,
okay,
we know that there are adults
coming up north into California,
which is very cold water for them.
They're used to the,
the warmer water in the Gulf
of California. So okay, can
they have babies up here?
Basically,
are we going to get a reproducing
population establishing
itself as the range is
expanding.
And it's an interestingly at the same
time as I was figuring out that the little
babies needed warm water and
they were actually very finicky.
They're teeny this hilarious thing.
So that you have grown up as big as me.
And when they're babies hatch though
like a grain of rice and they're quite
finicky and they need warm water and
they need very special food and it's,
it's kind of the Nautilus problem.
Even we couldn't feed them anything and
we would give them everything we would
think of and they would just starve
in the lab. And now, all right,
we'll go back to the ocean, find
whatever you were meant to find. Um, and,
and it seems interesting that while
I was finding that they had this very
particular need as babies,
the invasion as everyone is calling it
of California just kind of slowed down.
And eventually now fishermen
off California and further
north hardly ever find
Humboldt squid.
They're pretty much all retreated
back to their native range in Mexico.
And even there they've gotten
a lot smaller. So it's, it's,
it's been fun to see in practice the
sort of flexibility that I talked about
because the species as a whole
is still doing really well.
But you can see them responding year
by year and even season by season two,
the way the ocean changes.
That's very cool.
All right,
thanks for the awesome talk.
So this is a strange question,
but given the absence of
preserve south buddy features,
how do we know that extinct
cephalopods even add denticles
that's a great question. Um, how do we
even know that they had tentacles? Ah,
I'm going to go to the
short answer is we don't,
maybe they didn't have tentacles at all.
And in particular,
sorry, these guys,
these really early ones.
I think that in a way,
the only reason people draw them with
tentacles is to show that we know they're
cephalopods because that's
the defining feature. Um,
but they might not have
had 10 nickels at all.
Interestingly by this point here,
which is the,
the branching point where you get
the lineage of the Nautilus is,
and then the lineage going to
all your modern cephalopods.
We're pretty sure that they would have
had tentacles by then because tentacles,
the f and the tentacles
come from the foot. So the,
the ancestral cephalopod was related
to a snail which has a big foot that it
uses around on.
And so we know because of studying the
way they develop in the egg that what
happens is that foot splits into
tentacles quite early on in development.
And that happens in embryonic nautilus
and in embryonic squid at the same time
and with the same number.
So it's always 10 to begin with.
Even with a novelists that eventually
gets up to 60 or 90 tentacles.
And because that trait
seems to be so conserved,
it's thought that it probably goes
way back to this split that there's an
incestual cephalopod trait of having
a foot that divides into 10 tentacles.
And then that evolved in Nautilus is
at some point to be just the slight
plethora of tentacles. And
in squid two of those, those,
the and the were all equals equal
length as well because you do get a few
fossils up over here that have
these 10 equal link pinnacles.
And so two of them in squid
became much longer and elastic,
two of them in octopus has disappeared.
But even an octopus is,
we know that the ancestral characteristic
was to have 10. Uh, and so that's,
that's sort of the answers were pretty
sure that by here they had tentacles and
some point in here it probably evolved.
It would have been useful.
If you think about being
a snail up in the water,
how do you get your food then maybe
you just have a really flexible foot.
Just one question. Um, thank
you for the music talk, um,
question about chromatophores and when
they evolved and if there is a way to
tell when they evolved. And then a
second part of the question there, Raja,
is that just a mollusk trait?
And that's how they know that that's what
the tongue looked like when they were
going back and creating
imagery or how do they tell?
Right? So two different
traits. The chromatophores,
the color changing ability and the the
gradular. Um, so I'll take the bride,
you'll have first,
since there's more physical evidence for
it and the ratchet is a moleskin traits.
So you'll see Rachel is in
snails, even in clams, um,
all kinds of different mollusks.
And in fact,
all of the different snail ratchet
[inaudible] are useful because snails,
snails eat and a lot of different ways.
And I don't mean just um,
Darden snails at this point.
There are a lot of marine snails and
their marine snails that scrape food off
rocks.
And there were marines sales that are
predators that eat other fish in their
marine snails that float actually float
through the water and catch plankton.
And so looking at all of those different
Ragland's is the main way that the
paleontologist who begin to
look at ammonite fragilize
cephalopod is kind of say,
okay,
what would it have been good for it?
Does it look more like the snail that
he's plankton or the snail that eats LG or
these things? And so the, um,
the ratchet itself is usually
not preserved independently
as a fossil because
it's quite delicate and it probably
just falls apart. And so I,
if am remembering right,
the only real radicals that are found
are when they're inside a shell.
And so either the shell has to be
physically broken and then it's,
it's sort of just luck
whether you actually find
the regular or whether you've
destroyed it by breaking the shell or
you see it by doing essentially like an
electronic dissection with a CT scan.
MMM.
And then for the chromatophore far as,
that's a very good question.
We think that probably that amazing skin
and amazing color changing skin evolved
around the same time that the shell shell,
Shell,
Shell went internal, which is in this
lineage called the Polaroids. And, um,
this is one of these fun facts that I
only learned when I started researching my
book. I, a phd did not
teach me this, but, um,
when you're doing all this sedimological
research because people ask you
questions coldly,
oid means scabbard.
So this whole group is named because
their bodies became like the scabbards for
their shell. It was internalized
and cover it up. Uh,
and so once the shell goes internal,
which is this little light colored thing,
it's still chambered.
It's still buoyant.
It was still quite
substantial for a long time,
but it was no longer
something you could hide in.
And so at that point it would have been
extremely advantageous for the skin to
develop some method of protection.
And so we think that that's probably
when both camouflage and ink sacs are
likely to have evolved.
But there's,
there's precious little in the
fossil record about either one.
So put it on my like three
third grader hat here.
Do we call them tentacles
because there are 10 of them.
Oh, that's such a good
question. Um, it is, ah,
it is technically,
yeah,
wrong to call them all tend to go
kind of gentler word for take
it again, it's, it's wrong. Um,
they're all arms really.
And the word tentacles is best to reserve
for those two really elastic ones.
Uh,
so a squid or a cuddle fish,
if you've ever maybe seen a video of
them catching prey or you can go home and
look one up, um, they have their arms
that are just always the same length.
Then maybe they might grab slow moving,
pray with it,
but if they need to catch a fish
or something that's really fast,
they have these elastic tentacles that
go shoot and catch it and bring it back
in. It's like milliseconds. It's a really,
really fast and those are the tentacles.
So squid have them cuddle fish have
them occupy says do not have them. Um,
so technically squid and cuddle fish are
the only ones with true tentacles and,
but you can remember them
not because of the 10 part,
but because the word tentacle is longer
than the word arm and tentacles are
longer than arms.
I have one more if it's okay.
Um,
so since the seas are acidifying,
I had a question about the
shells because you're saying
the, the bitty squids and
octopuses are having a problem.
Are they a calcium carbonate shell or
they silica based and their calcium
carbonate. Okay. Um, all the, even the
cuddle bone, which is the internal Shell,
um,
and the squid for the most
part is not even calcified.
So that's one of the reasons that squid
seem to be a bit more resilient to ocean
acidification is they don't have very
much that's actually calcified. Um,
but the Nautilus Shell and the cuttlefish
shell are our calcium. Interestingly,
there is one other place that all of
the cephalopods have a bit of calcium
carbonate that's very
sensitive to acidification and
it's these little bones in
their ears,
teeny little bones called satellites
that help them tell up from down.
We actually have similar little teeny
tiny bones in our ears that rock around
and they're what make you sick
on merry go rounds. And how,
you know when you're facing up and when
you're pointed down and the development
of those teeny little bones in
cephalopods seems to be quite affected by
acidified waters.
And so there's some risk that we might
end up with ocean's full of sort of
disoriented,
lost the squid that can't figure
out which way is up and down.
Uh, we haven't gotten there yet
though, so I think it was crest.
Oh, thank you Deanna. Thank you everyone
for coming. Let's keep him around a plot.